[Music]
so good afternoon welcome to this
session my name is Ben Chong I'm a
product manager on cloud storage so my
primary mission and goal in life right
now is to help you guys get your data
onto gcp today we have a bunch of slides
so let's keep questions until the end
and i'll be around like you guys want to
talk to me individually after this
session so let's start the afternoon
with talking about googles mission I
think guys in my approach is already so
our mission is to organize the world's
information and to make it universally
accessible and useful and to achieve
this mission we have built this like
really big no complex advanced global
architecture and infrastructure and with
cloud platform we are basically making
this same the same set of tools and such
structure available to you so that you
can also organize your company's
information and make it accessible and
useful right with machine learning
bigquery and so on now the the kido in
order to use all these tools they're
available in cloud platforms that you
need to get your data in Roger conveys
information needs to be brought on to
gcp so they can run vickery you can use
the new span and tools and so on I mean
we'll kind of cover that today so let's
cover two types of data sources and two
times of data right first let's talk
about unstructured data so unstructured
data is what we call fouls soltero file
system in your data center and
structured data databases what is big
data or my sequel databases and so on
let's say we instructed data first so
when we talk about unstructured data on
cloud platform is basically Google Cloud
storage transferred is where
unstructured data lives we all know it I
hope we all love it as well think of it
as your cloud hard drive so like GCE
maybe or cpu and cluster is your hard
drive we have to
sort of storage multivision original for
live data so data that changes all the
time that you're using for compute
workloads to serve media content to your
customers and end users and then we have
two classes near line and cool line for
colder storage there's a kind of data
that you are not planning to touch for
like 30 days or 90 days and it's worth
soaring in to near 90 coline I'm not
going to go into a lot of details here
there are details online there were
sessions earlier this week that they
went into some details on how to use GCS
for performance and so on all that
content will be available after the
events if you have specific questions do
reach out to your sales reps they are
there to answer your questions the next
couple of slides covers kind of like
very high level considerations like you
know what should you think about when
you use cloud storage so storage tier so
i covered the four storage tiers you
want to make sure that you choose the
right ones for the right workloads it's
not the end of the world if you don't
you know choose the right one you can
always move data around the only thing
you want to make sure that if you start
off with objects in your line of code
line you may incur what you call
division charges if UD eat them before
30 days or 90 days data locality can
depend on two factors of data locality
is like where are your consumers as a
consumer of the data if the data is
going to be consumed by compute compute
is kind of like regional right like us
central u.s. East English case and you
want to make sure your buckets are
nearby so you want to choose regional
markets versus multivision buckets and
what one thing that a lot of evoke at
get caught by his bucket names are kind
of based on a global namespace so your
bucket name has to be pretty unique
don't use personally identifiable
information to name a bucket and then
you should create your pockets pre
create pockets if necessary as opposed
to come including the bucket creation in
your work through additional
consideration so if have lots of pockets
you eat instead of you know con named
request rates if you are planning to do
a lot of write requests you want to
scale up instead of like hitting the
system all of a sudden
we do have no certain similarities
actually in a sense of if you have
sequential names you probably don't want
to kind of like write the objects see
Christian names one after another
because that will impact performance as
well so so let's go into the knee right
so how do you get data into GCS let's go
show Paul to understand straw poll to
understand like what kind of networks
are you guys have who has like one gig
networks like uplink okay 10 gigs how
many of you don't know what kind of
network you have okay did so how quickly
and easily you can upload data into GCS
depends on a cloud network right so this
is what we call laws of physics and
speed of light so imagine you have just
one king network uplink assuming one
hundred percent utilization so nobody
else is doing emails you've got one
petabyte of data and taking more than
three months so so these are
considerations so a lot of times you
don't think about networking it thinking
about moving data so my point here is
that less thing about network network is
part of the equation of uploading data
into GCS or gcp which brings us to the
next slide so here's how we can look at
the wall right so distance to gcp is the
x-axis so if your data is in GCS or in
another cloud it is closer to gcp if you
are if your data is on location we know
network at all your kind of like really
far away and then the y-axis is the
amount of data now if your data is in
GCS like for example you have a data in
the bucket in Europe you want to movie
to the US so that's kind of like point
zero if your data is in another cloud by
ash tree you're not too far away and we
have a tool called transfer service for
them what's transfer service o clock
source transfer service is essentially
three step process to quickly import
online data into GCS right so it's
really good for moving data from a
street to GCS GCS the GTS transferred I
was saying you know if you have data
from one region
you can move it to another region or if
you want to like earlier if you kind of
selected a multi-regional bucket and you
realize that oh maybe it's better for
the data to be in a regional bucket then
you can use transfer service to do
migration very popular use cases right
so we have customers who s three
customers and we are finally that right
this is kind of like you know opencart
well they back up your data to GCS where
the primary secondary backups and the
use transfer service right daily we're
talking about you know petabytes of data
a week a lot of customers again like
complete were closed in gns3 in AWS deal
of bigquery so what they do they use
transfer service to move their log files
and other data across the GCS import
into bigquery transfer service allows
you to schedule a one-time sensors or
recurring transfers and you can do
hourly transfers as well so waste
transfer service transfer service is not
a tool that you can install it is a
cloud-hosted tool so you go to our cloud
console you can find it under the
storage section right under call
transfer obviously when you click on
transfer you will get a list of transfer
jobs and then if you click on the
creation so John you can then create a
transfer job so step one would be you
specify your sauce so it could be a
cloud Google's GCS bucket s3 bucket we
can actually transfer from HTTP HTTPS
sources and then you can kind of
specified conditions right so transfer
files Andy with certain prefixes or
exclude files with Senator fixes how
many of you know like why prefixes are
important in object storage not meaning
so object storage is kind of like a flat
storage right so there's no concept of
folders like physical folders and
directories so a lot of customers they
use prefixes to kind of like identifying
folders so for example in your local
file system you may have a slash and be
/c / object or file
where the slashes are kind of denote
your directory limitations so when you
import that file into GCF you can it
will be named for example aah PSNC /
file name Rio object name so the
directory prefixes becomes part of the
the file name of the object name and so
by using these critics conditions you
can say that ok I'm going to transfer
only certain files in certain folders or
directories into GCS step so and another
way of defining source would be amazon
s3 right so you define that enter the
name of the s3 bucket access key ID and
the secret access key and all those
things you can get from the Amazon
console so step two is where you
identify the destination and you do have
transfer options where you you know
overwrite the destination if it already
exists or DV objects at the source or
you delete objects if the source object
has been defeated right so it's kind of
like a synchronization mechanism and if
I me I'll step three is where you
configure the transfer right we can run
it now or you can run it at a later time
you know on daily basis and then when
you click on create and it creates a
transfer job it gets queued up for for
running alright so let's transfer
service for you obviously tips I think
this a recap of earlier but you can do
all these things and you can click yeah
so you can create a silly tea for
transfer jobs one of our parts so that
gives you an hourly syncing to cancel
all right so we're talk about transfer
service so what if your data is in a
Colo or in your own data center but we
could network connectivity so for that
we have a tool conscious you two are
means all lowercase so Jessie kills our
primary command line tool right it runs
on Windows Linux Mac Linux Mac it can
run on GC instance you can even run it
on ec2 instance if you like it's
actively maintained actively supported
unique Spanish syntax lots of
documentation there's also
stackoverflow discussion sub performance
Jess util can run northeast edit so you
can have multiple processes that will
upload data in parallel if you have lots
of like large the data files you can
Jess you too can break up the data files
into chunks to upload the chunks in
parallel and then once uploaded you can
it will reconstitute the original file
and delete the chunks so that that's
where any there's a caution there if you
are uploading like using this feature to
upload to near line of code line when
you delete the chunks you do in curl or
you call a deviation penalty so download
has the same benefits so retry so we do
have retry logic for transient network
serious there are more details i'm not
going to go into each and every line and
then there's something called a manifest
file so we can generate a manifest file
automatically when we run in manifest
files will indicate you can see the
example there of which objects or files
were successfully transferred and then
failures as well and in manifest file
itself can be using it as an input into
GSU till so you can do an auto retry all
failures so a lot of customers uses that
we are in lock cases because we are
running HTTP requests sometimes we they
are the alias right so for whatever
reason if all is not uploaded so you can
use the mini set size and input so to
make sure that you know you have a
million valves that all of them are
actually uploaded effectively there's
also resume ability so there's automatic
for large objects and then there is the
resume file that you can that we use to
track like uploading process so if
that's a block you know for whatever
reason we can can do a resume using this
data so tips and tricks I think the key
one is the first bullet point right so
if you have lots of data like a huge
data sets you want a partition that data
set and use multiple hosts for transfers
multiple hosts beans like physical
machines or VMs and each one will run
its
own instance of GSU till uploading a
section of your data source what this
does is that then you effectively has a
whole bunch of GSU two instances and
threads uploading the data at the same
time kind of saturating your network as
much as possible we don't we don't have
any network traveling so you have to
kind of use other tricks like trickle or
and foster the bama visualization at the
network layer if you are concerned about
politics meta data at all there's a dash
B option there was recently introduced
to capture the politics attributes of
your source files and saw that as a GCS
Manor data as part of the objectives in
GCS all right so jess util itself is a
relatively basic tool we don't do kind
of like network optimization so you if
you wanna even better transfer speeds we
have partners Tavella with cloud Fast
Pass espero bits [ __ ] so some of them
they do UDP or TCP optimization right
for better speeds all right so what is
your data sources I locations right with
low bandwidth or no bandwidth at all so
the tradition there is offline data
transfer offline import/export well
import in this case so what this means
is that you have a physical source media
with the hard drives or social plans you
load the data in their ship the hardware
to an ingestion point with good network
and someone there will ingest the data
to GCS for you we have several
third-party providers to do this we
launched this collaboration about a year
and a half ago so in North America we
have iron mountain you can see the
pricing gear in amia and a tegra prime
focus technologies so we have a bunch of
customers using these services customers
essentially sign up with this third
party service providers like separately
from google now the law of use cases are
where data is generated
offline for example at c collected on
hard drive so when the ship you just
port what they do that they ship the
hard drive so I Mountain get a data
interested it's not necessarily a lot of
data where as long as you are talking
about gigabytes or hundreds of gigabytes
of data but you know when you're out as
see you can't be on generally you can
even send one point right if you don't
have network so so they kind of use this
offline method now what what's new here
is that we just started working with
Zatara to offer life my offline
migration of live data they have a booth
downstairs if you guys want to talk to
them about this so how this works is
that they will send you like two
appliances you capture the data onto the
appliances you ship one to Adara they
will upload to GCS and then they use the
second appliance to do synchronization
of data that has changed right so if
your think about like the hard drive
approach basically you're taking a
snapshot loading of your data loading
into the hard drive shipping it out but
wipe your data evolves right so the
other account solves that problem and
because they're using soy appliances you
know you could capture a lot more data
than on individuals like 10 terabyte
hard drive since the summary so we have
transfer service right for cloud data
Jess you kill and partner products for
for data in locations with good Network
if you have if you don't have a lot of
data right say under 100 terabytes or so
you can use like hard driving towards
right because if you have more more data
than the number of hard drives become
kind of unmanageable we have more data
or live data and then this other for you
alright so let's cover structured data
now structured data is more partner
plane so we have number of partners who
can help you migrate data from
on-premise data bases or even other
cloud databases to Clark sequel and
spanner so we have informatica expensive
supports both flavors or plots people
write my sequel impose
gress of segments stitched allen and
illumise apport postgres sequel and BB
visit eternity suppose my sequel only
similarly if you're interesting
importing data into data proc we have a
whole bunch of partners for that and and
depending on where you want to land the
data whether on GCS or persistent disk
we have different patterns supporting
the different targets so if i'm going to
pick a big query data integration
partners so again partner play right
generally everything from or cost as
data sources so those are marketing crm
data sources databases like my sequel
sequel server post grants oracle or data
warehouses like teradata particular
natesa now pit crew is becoming very
popular in marketeers right so you can
use bigquery to analyze the likely
grades and all that to kind of figure
out like whether your advertising
campaign you see practice so we just
announced big query data transfer
service and that basically allows you to
import data from you know google app
platforms into bigquery for analysis now
we also support other sources right of
marketing data so whether adobe
analytics Facebook Twitter and so on
through our panel ecosystem so you can
check out the link here this basically a
pre updated to kind of like give you an
idea of which partners are available to
do this data import and then you know be
sure to your to wrap as well if you have
like editions so we have cover
unstructured data and structured data
let's talk about IT workflow perspective
this is actually a summary of the talk I
had yesterday just but about three four
slides so I see workflows are generally
things like you know bursting caching
backup disaster recovery hearing and
archiving very
how can I t you you know I t stop
running this standard workflows how can
they get data on to the cloud so-called
good thing what's that right so Club the
thing is essentially you are running
workloads on-premise on your own data in
data centers and you want to take
advantage of what we can offer in the
top right for compute for example like
low cost scale you know in scale over
and then you care about making sure that
the data there's on-premises available
to the compute were closed in the cloud
and then you're done the big hassle of
like you know explicitly like moving
data around we partnered with a via for
example they are really great for
compute high-performance compute because
they allow you to store data and there's
on-premise make the data available for
compute instances in the cloud or vice
versa which is you have data in the
cloud right game bondage of low-cost GCS
and then allowing on-premise computer
access the data is in a town so to talk
about backup so if you have existing
backup solutions you can very very
easily retarget right your your backup
destination to the cloud so we work with
partners like very tart and so on and
it's just a UI change you can see the
the example here on the on the right and
then you have existing you don't have
existing backup solutions we again we
are working with a lot of partners that
will def support us today so you can
then talk to them if you don't have
accessing backup solutions but then your
workflow or data set is very simple then
you can use like cloud gateway solutions
again we have a lot of partners that
they will support you on that cloud
curing is interesting right so there are
two ways of looking except hearing one
well during one way of looking crowd
cheering which is you have data by
on-premise storage where you hold of
your data now the problem on primary
storage is that is reacts pensive so why
not move some of that data to cloud
right to take care like take advantage
of our scale and low cost especially
like coal line for example
and so you can count like Nick space for
four additional kind of like live data
on premise so we have a particle
comprised that can do analyze analysis
of your data usage on premise and they
can identify which data is kind of like
cold data and it can help them help you
move the data across to the cloud based
on policy and so on another way of doing
it if you know if you are unloading new
storage devices or storage technologies
can go with on-premise object storage
vendors like cloud in here and they do
automatic tiering right so making sure
that the colder data automatically gets
kid to GCS so somewhere in here is that
you know for what kind of IT workflows
that you have and if you want to kind of
like lavish a cloud or even explore
moving some of the data the clock we
have a whole ecosystem of partners for
them okay so wrap up if there's one
thing to remember is this line right so
we have different data sources different
that generation and what the
destinations and what are the solutions
okay so everything from a stream to IT
workflows Klaus cloud storage databases
clasico for example and plan the
solutions transfer service and so on so
if you are planning to ingest data into
gcp reach out to your sales rep all
right there's a lot of things that we
are doing that we can't talk about
publicly so your sales rep may be able
to kind of like talk to you more under
NDA about all the stuff that we are
doing as a PM responsible for injection
I want to make you guys make sure that
you guys are successful moving a data in
the cloud so you know where you have
again like data ingestion projects and
so on we shud through your sales rep
they'll get back to me and then we can
potentially work together alright thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
you